it's like being on a roller coaster but
it's all taking place in virtual reality
along with seats that shaken vibrate
virtual reality goggles make this ski
jump seem like the real thing five
minutes of outdoor adventure inside the
convention hall there is more than a
games that it looks really real so I
couldn't emmis I couldn't convince them
out a lady was fake so I mean I'm gonna
be on the official thing is no too scary
yes of course yes yeah very scary it
looks like reality so we are completely
emerging side and you're thinking like
that and unreal willing to this very
question vr goggles are a big hit at
this year's Mobile World Congress in
Barcelona this company from Denmark is
working on the optimization of virtual
reality applications these goggles are
designed to track the viewers eye
movements focusing only on what he sees
at the moment because now we're trying
to save processing power if you know
where the eyes are looking you can fully
power the graphics at that point saving
power everywhere else so you don't have
to process everything at the same time
but it's going to you by Guardian focus
japan's epson company is offering
professional users such as drone pilots
the latest version of its augmented
reality glasses they allow the wearer to
view additional data along with whatever
he sees in front of him manufacturers
are marketing smart glasses like these
for a variety of users we are targeting
a lot of use cases and market
requirements for example around museums
the arts the entertainment park all the
theaters for example but as well
anything related to training giving
practical training to new entrance in
companies for example and finally
software developers are trying their
luck at the fair microgaming is a
British company that designs online
casino software they brought along this
virtual game of roulette which allows
players to enter another world this may
well be what the future of gaming looks
like